[Musique]
je m'appelle et billy et j'ai 37 ans je
travaille depuis presque quinze ans dans
le marketing et récemment j'ai découvert
un nouveau monde
le monde du numérique et du digital
alors mes études étaient bien loin donc
ça m'a demandé beaucoup de remises en
question
alors c'est génial j'ai appris des
nouveaux modes de fonctionnement une
nouvelle façon d'agir mais je ne suis
pas là ce soir pour vous parler de ma
carrière professionnelle
non je me suis là ce soir pour vous
partager marlotte j'écoute ça fait des
années que j'ai honte
et d'ailleurs je pense même que mes
proches pour moi donc ce soir j'ai envie
d'être moi même de me libérer du regard
des autres et de pouvoir enfin avancer
je m'appelle et me dit j'ai 37 ans et
pendant presque 15 ans j'ai été deux
femmes vêtues allonger la boule au
ventre ce soir mais je ne veux pas de
votre pitié
j'ai grandi dans les années 80 ans en
région parisienne et comme toutes les
petites filles de mon âge je regardais
les princesses 10 et vous vous souvenez
un jour mon prince est donc j'ai attendu
au prince et sa fortement encouragées
par ma mère qui va les encourager à
tendres légumes jeune fille sérieuse
élève modèle
il a bien fallu que j'exprime mon côté
rebelle qu'elle répare ce fut donc en
choisissant mon prince charmant
j'ai jeté mon dévolu sur le rebelle lui
c'est le bad boy quoi alors j'ai été
particulièrement comblé un bad boy
puisque dès les premières semaines j'ai
reçu ma correction
la première correction oui j'avais un
peu trop regardé un garçon lors d'une
boum alors j'aurais dû avoir peur
j'aurais dû m'inquiéter il s'est excusé
et il avait l'air tellement sincère il
va premier qu'il recommencerait pas
évidemment c'était pas vrai je ne savais
pas ce vent précise que j'avançais ma
descente aux enfers que j'avançais une
destruction psychologique et physique
alors pour vous illustrer cette
destruction et pour être à l'aise pour
vous la transmettre
j'ai décidé de l'illustrer avec éclat ce
qui me tient à coeur la cuisine je suis
plutôt gourmande
alors je me suis dit ça te fera bien
comme dans toute recette de cuisine il
faut des ingrédients
alors bien évidemment pour les puristes
il s'agit d'une métaphore on va prendre
comme ingrédient un jouet le jouer c'est
moi c'est peut-être vous voit doazit
d'un côté vos amis alors comment est on
choisit faut jouer la résistance du
jouet peut-être proportionnelle à la
perversité du cuisinier sinon c'est pas
drôle de le jouer risquerait de casser
avant la fin de la recette on peut donc
commencer maintenant la première étape
la claque et la caresse étape très
importante puisque c'est à ce moment là
que votre jouet d'avenir doit devenir
complètement dépendant complètement
raide dingue amoureux alors il faut
alterner des périodes d'humiliation de
coûts avec des périodes de lune de miel
n'hésitez pas dans les extrêmes
ça rendra votre jouer d'autant plus
dépendants qu'il pensera vivre une
passion extrême avec vous ah oui parce
que 10 des films
série voir la télé une fois vos blu ray
bien dépendant on peut passer à l'étape
suivante
l'isolation alors là deux écoles
l'isolation cérébral ou l'isolation
physique
moi j'ai eu la france c'est un
aventurier nous sommes donc partis à dix
mille kilomètres vivre à l'est de la
réunion
j'étais loin de ma famille de mes amis
plus aucun témoin pour pouvoir si jamais
jamais un moment de faiblesse pouvoir
partager
c'est à ce moment là où les humiliations
les coûts s'accentue pour amorcer encore
plus sept dessins s'instaure alors un
climat de peur et dans ce climat on peut
y ajouter des accessoires
c'est beaucoup plus drôle le faut
stimuler un petit peu la créativité fait
très bien prendre un revolver vous le
positionne à sion l'attend s'attendre à
un petit instant ensuite vous le retirez
vous rigoleriez vous dit rien
t'inquiète pas c'était juste des balles
à blanc c'était juste pour voir sa
réaction
on peut aussi invité un jeune public
ça fait sourire et est généralement les
les mamans et leurs enfants comme tendon
d'achille j'ai tenu quinze ans avec
cette recette
alors je vais aborder la première
question taboue pourquoi je suis resté
alors j'ai déjà entendu dans des
conversations à elle n'avait qu'à partir
l aveca à redire ça sent tellement
simple non alors je n'ai pas de réponse
toute faite
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
j'étais amoureuse au début mais à la fin
j'étais complètement aliénés par cet
homme aline et par la peur est obligé de
m'adapter pour survivre alors on
s'adapte
comme je vous le disais et en s'adaptant
j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle darwinisme
conjugale s'adapter ou crevé j'ai décidé
de m'adapter
donc on voit apparaître des
prédispositions au web est clos ou bien
au contraire on se voit révéler de
nouvelles facultés
je vais vous en partager quelques-unes
la première faculté l'agent secret
j'avais constamment un sac sous le pied
de mon lit avec un doute de mes clefs de
voiture des affaires de rechange les
issues de secours
bien connu pour être prête avec ces
livrets
n'importe quand les papiers étaient chez
mes parents je n'avais rien je pouvais
de partir à tout moment un agent secret
sa servante aussi ce double vie ma vie
au travail
ma vie avec les années ma vie dans des
patients et sport en même temps cette
double vie c'est ce qui m'a permis de
tenir la journée j'avais une vie normale
ensuite il y à l'hyper perfection et le
contrôle ça c'était plutôt une
prédisposition jeta alors dans ces
moments là on fait attention à tout à ce
qu'on dit quand on parle commenceront
samedi
est ce qu'on fait à manger et libertaire
fiction c'est aussi un moment avec cette
perte de confiance en soi de chercher
les styles quelque part alors moi je
vais chercher dans mes études il est
chargé le travail pour avoir une
reconnaissance objective c'est aussi le
moyen de mettre en sécurité
je contrôle tout parce que je suis la
seule à pouvoir garantir ma sécurité
enfin la dissociation ça c'est un pur
mécanisme de survie votre corps est très
bien fait il peut nous prémunir en fait
des dangers et nous permettre d'agir
moi j'étais dans un danger permanent en
quarts avant j'étais branché dame qui
faisait équipe et tout le temps donc
j'ai débranché mon cerveau avec mon
autre sens à mon corps j'ai fonctionné
comme ça pendant des années alors
comment est il s'en sort oser c'est
accepter l'un peut accepter de perdre le
contrôle et plus lâcher prise dans un
moment de faiblesse après un épisode un
peu plus violente d'habitude j'ai y
travaillent
j'ai appelé mon ami à l'aide et là tout
d'un coup le regard extérieur
s'introduisent ml je comprenais alors la
normalité
situation je suis de lire dans tomates
je suis allé chez lui de st j'ai porté
plainte j'ai fait mon sac j'ai pris ma
fille et je suis parti mais alors quand
l'époux s'arrête
est ce que c'est pour autant qu'on va
mieux dans 89 % des cas les victimes de
violences conjugales extreme des
conséquences graves tentative de suicide
angoisse peur j'étais pas à l'abri de ça
bon cru
c'est là qu'intervient un deuxième et
agro la honte d'autant plus que c'est
les hommes violents sont parfois très
bien inséré socialement
donc on a aussi la peur qu'on ne le
croit pas et la peur de déstabiliser par
rapport à ces stable par rapport à ceux
proches pouvaient représenter ce
conjoint violent
c'était mon cas donc j'en ai parlé à
personne ni mais par un lit mes amis ni
mon nouvel amoureux n'était du court
donc j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle une
résilience absolue j'ai tout mis sous le
tapis
et puis j'ai fait ce qu'on attendait de
moi j'ai essayé d'être heureuse
j'allais tout pour être heureuse ma
fille ou un turban en sécurité mes
parents sont du vivant près de moi je me
suis mariée avec un homme extraordinaire
j'ai un bon job
tous les ingrédients d'un happy end mais
voilà mon corps a décidé de parler tout
seul
insomnie migraine ulcère à langer
d'abord réagi de façon cartésienne je
suis allé chez le médecin j'ai pris
beaucoup de médicaments j'ai fait
beaucoup d'examens faire durer plus de
cinq ans au bout de cinq enjeux sont
baptisés toujours résultèrent j'ai donc
essayé une autre approche j'ai libéré la
parole une deuxième fois j'ai longuement
parlé à mes proches et je me suis sentie
et ce à partir de ce moment là que j'ai
commencé à vraiment construction parce
qu'au final je ne sais plus qui j'étais
qui est il et entre la personne qui a
évolué et qui s'est adapté à ce que
j'aime vraiment et puis ce corps que je
touchais plus que je regardais plus que
je n'habitais plus j'étais enfermé dans
une cage avec ces mécanismes de survie
alors j'ai tenté beaucoup de méthodes
sophrologie ostéopathie micro qu'il est
kinésithérapie à l'acupuncture de toutes
ces méthodes
j'ai gardé des outils et ça va apporter
du bien mais je n'habitais toujours pas
réellement mon corps j'ai alors décidé
d'habiter vraiment son corps j'ai donc
travaillé l'énergie pris conscience que
mon corps était bloqué j'ai fait du yoga
est ce que vous connaissez la cause la
signification du yoga unir le corps et
l'esprit pour ne faire plus qu'un ça
tombe bien c'est ce que je recherchais
je me suis aussi dit à la méditation
pour pouvoir prendre conscience de moi
de ce qui m'entourait et d'être ancré en
toute sécurité dans l'environnement qui
était maintenant le mien récemment j'ai
aussi libéré la parole avec un
professionnel donc j'étais plutôt
contente parce que je m'étais des mots
sur mes traumatisme et je me suis sentie
moins seule et moins folle aussi et je
me suis rendu compte avec beaucoup de
bienveillance
au final j'étais juste un un soldat
revenu de la guerre qui avait vu vécu et
fait des choses difficiles et si
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler alors
que je ne suis pas encore réparées c'est
pour que vous puissiez libérer la parole
et prendre conscience du pouvoir
salvateur des mots soyons vigilants
il est important aussi de libérer la
parole pour éduquer nos enfants
bien sûr aussi je les dis à ma fille de
croire au prince charmant mais je lui
expliquerai que quatre princesse sur 10
connaître des violences et que donc elle
aura peut-être la chance de sa vie de
rencontrer un mauvais pain charmant
parce que oui nous adolescents veulent
vivre tous des choses existantes comme
on voit dans les films vous savez la
banalise la violence le sexe la passion
et puis vous a dû tout ne comprendraient
pas bien sûr alors ce qui va falloir
leur expliquer c'est qu'une petite
claque elle c'est déjà le début de la
violence intrafamiliale et que les
conséquences avions beaucoup plus
longtemps qu'un film de 90 minutes
et soyons honnêtes nous passons du temps
à éduquer nos enfants ou mon envisage d'
éduquer nos enfants sur le risque lié
aux drogues aux mst aux grossesses pour
les filles mais est-ce qu'on leur parle
d'eux
le gall non enfin tu vois pas souvent
alors ce soir je vous invite à faire ce
soir nous allons avoir deux prendre la
décision d' éduquer vos enfants pour
pouvoir transmettre les risques liés aux
violences conjugales ou alors laisser
internet ou la télé le faire et dieu
sait que ça m'insupporte
ce soir je vous ai parlé est maintenant
jugé plus longtemps merci
[Musique]